février 1828 dans une petite île battue
par les vents
mais un écrivain dont l'oeuvre
extraordinaire traduite en plus de cent
seize langues restent encore aujourd'hui
celle qui est le plus lu dans le monde
entier
il s'appelait jules verne avril 1926 un
écrivain américain décide de créer une
revue dans laquelle il publiera des
textes de prophétie scientifique dit il
et comme il n'est guère satisfait de ce
terme il va en créer un autre qui fera
littéralement fortune science-fiction
avril 1979 pour la première fois en
europe et créer un magazine de
télévision entièrement consacrée à la
science fiction temps x eh bien oui
temps x et donc votre magazine le
magazine de tous ceux qui aiment et
connaissent la science fiction bien sûr
mais également de tous ceux qui
s'intéressant à l'avenir souhaitant
découvrir certains aspects que sera
notre monde demain telle est la question
que se posent les auteurs de science
fiction et c'est de cette réponse que
découle toute la science fiction c'est à
dire une approche du futur par le veau
de l'imaginaire et avant tout par la
voie du romain depuis jules verne tenez
vous bien à plus de 50 milles textes ont
été publiés
et puis il ya bien sûr le cinéma qui n'a
pas entendu parler ou vu des films comme
rencontre du troisième type ou encore la
guerre des étoiles
et puis il ya encore la bande dessinée
la musique le cinéma le théâtre même la
sculpture de science fiction
bref on peut dire aujourd'hui que la
science fiction est bel et bien partout
alors partons à la découverte à la
découverte de ce nouveau et passionnant
domaine de la culture où tout est
possible et avant tout commençons par
l'actualité
chaque semaine nous vous présenterons
des informations des films des ouvrages
que nous sélectionnerons exprès pour
vous et qui nous paraîtront les plus
intéressants d'autre part dans leurs
rubriques temps x à la une
nous mettrons en valeur chaque fois un
événement particulièrement important
dans le champ de la science fiction
il pourra s'agir bien sûr d'ouvragés
libres âge il s'agit également de tout
autre chose
alan de temps x cette semaine andré
ruellan l'auteur de science fiction bien
connu et enfin pour tous ceux qui
veulent rêver au futur eh bien eh bien
nous ferons une découverte des grands
thèmes de science fiction
et cette fois-ci nous commencerons par
le voyage dans l'espace
ce que nous mettrons en question tout à
l'heure en compagnie du physicien jean
pierre petit voilà c'est comme je vous
le disais tout à l'heure à un voyage que
nous vous invitons à un fabuleux voyage
qui nous mènera très loin jusqu'aux
frontières du possible
alors attention nous ne sommes plus en
1979 temps x vous souhaite la bienvenue
dans l'avenir